[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein herzhaftes rezept ich
werde nämlich eine bosnische peter und
eine bosnische bodecker machen im
prinzip das sind sie zum balkan rezept
aber im prinzip sind türkische rezepte
bosnische rezept der bulgarische rezepte
griechische rezepte oftmals sehr ähnlich
weil ja alles auch so ein bisschen aus
dem osmanischen reich alles so abstand
aber ich will gar nicht so sehr in die
tiefe der geschichte gehen denn jeder
sagt habermann nein das ist unser rezept
nein das ist unsers ich mache einfach
ein herzhaftes leckeres rezept und zwar
habe ich das rezept von meiner besten
freundin von leila beziehungsweise von
ihrer mama von der peter und die partie
ist vegetarisch die man das gleich mit
schichtkäse und zeige euch aber auch
gleich wie ihr die fleischige variante
machen könnte das braker heißt dass
politiker ihr könnt zum in die
kommentare schreiben
das rezept ist übrigens auch super für
den ramadan geeignet denn ihr könnt ganz
toll vorbereitet
ihr könnt auch wenn er sagt mensch ich
mache mir jetzt auf einmal die arbeit
noch an einem tag einfach vier bis fünf
barricks beziehungsweise peters nämlich
die vom bakken also diese erste backzeit
nutzen und dann ganz gut auskühlen
lassen und einfrieren
so könnt ihr dann nämlich bei bedarf das
peter auftritt im backofen nochmal
übergießen mit der flüssigkeit erzähle
ich euch später und dann einfach zum
ramadan zum iftar abends also zum
fastenbrechen servieren oder auch wenn
jetzt kein ramadan monat habe euch dann
könnt ihr das einfach so vorbereiten und
habt immer barrick und peter auf vorrat
und der teig ist wirklich ein super
einfach teig ihr braucht dafür nämlich
nur zwei zutaten nämlich 500 gramm und
da habe ich ein ganz normales weizenmehl
das video nothelfer und 300 gramm wasser
und dieser teig wird ganz dünn wie so
eine art viel teig und dafür braucht ihr
nicht mal einen besonderen aus rolf
starb denn das ganze funktioniert dann
auf einer tischdecke auf türkisch heißt
dieses bildet rezept auch haarscharf
berater wie gesagt ähnlich
ich mache jetzt erstmal den teig dafür
brauchte die zwei zutaten entweder
verknetet er jetzt einfach das mehl mit
dem wasser mit der hand oder eben in der
küchenmaschine ich mache das hier ganz
kurz denn so habe ich einfach die hände
frei
[Musik]
am anfang kommt es einem so vor als wäre
es zu wenig wasser als wir dies nicht
verbinden
und je nachdem welches mählmann habe es
braucht man auch etwas mehr oder weniger
wasser so ein esslöffel aber es sieht
hier schon der teig wird gut aber er ist
noch hier leicht klumpig das heißt
müsste jetzt wirklich noch ordentlich
durchkneten dass es sich gut vermischt
und wirklich schön glatt wird ohne
klumpen mit der hand ist natürlich ein
bisschen schwieriger beziehungsweise
einfach bisschen kraft aufwenden aber
wenn er das so man dann habt ihr schon
mal ein schönes workout
[Musik]
der teig ist jetzt fertig wie ihr sehen
könnt richtig schön geschmeidig und ich
habe es auch wirklich kein wasser mehr
dazu gegeben
das waren einfach die 300 milliliter und
der muss jetzt ein bisschen ruhe damit
da entspannen kann
es soll wieder hoch hat ab und zu also
gebe ich ihnen hier in die schüssel
deckt ihn ab und zeigt euch jetzt schon
mal wie ich die vegetarische füllung
mache und diesen tag werde ich jetzt
aber nochmal zu bereiten das heißt ich
hab damit zweimal 500 gramm menge damit
eben einmal die vegetarische und einmal
die flasche parierte machen kann
für die vegetarische füllung nämlich 500
gramm schichtkäse drei eier 2 esslöffel
öl das in sonnenblumenöl einem hat
teelöffel salz und etwas pfeffer 150
gramm naturjoghurt und dreieinhalb
prozentigen 150 gramm tun um käse da
sage ich gleich was dazu und zum
überleben brauche ich noch 200 gramm
sahne
ich bin jetzt glaube ich sogar zum
ersten mal in meinen videos schichtkäse
deswegen zeige ich euch hier nochmal die
packung schichtkäse ist einfach ein
zehnprozentiger käse ähnlich wie quark
wenn ihr den jetzt nicht findet könnt
ihr auch quark nehmen wobei der ein
bisschen anders schmeckt als quark hat
zu diesen knackigen geschmack das heißt
sie wie es anders beschreiben soll und
schichten ihr soeben bisschen anders den
gibt es aber auch in jedem supermarkt
und hier habe ich noch den turm käse das
ist ein normaler käse der erinnert so
ein bisschen an schafskäse und
hüttenkäse ist aber von der struktur her
etwas anders und den turm dürft ihr aber
nicht vergleichen mit dem turm käse den
er vielleicht aus dem türkischen dorf
kennt denn der ton und käse dem ein papa
zum beispiel immer mitgebracht hat legal
natürlich man darf es keine käse sachen
importen auch früher haben das halte
mitgebracht der schmeckt viel zu stark
und er wurde auch früher immer in seinem
feld zubereitet und ich konnte es nie
essen
aber der ist wirklich super lecker
schmeckt wirklich wieso ein schafskäse
ganz mild und da ist eben auch schon so
bröckelig in der konsistenz also ist sie
negativ sondern eher positiv und das
habe ich jetzt selbst mit dazu gemacht
denn die vierte hat die hat eigentlich
nur diese schichtkäse komponenten mit
drin und ich glaube das passt aber jetzt
ganz gut dazu geschmacklich also die
füllung ist supereinfach in der
herstellung ihr nehmt jetzt einfach alle
zutaten die kommen hier rein schichtkäse
dann die eier zum binden
etwas öl salz und pfeffer ihr könnt auch
gerne mit zwiebeln würzen oder etwas
lauch schneiden oder einfach kräuter
nehmen
der joghurt kommt hier auch rein den
nomaden käse auch noch mit rein jetzt
verrührt ihr einfach alles ganz kurz und
dann ist die füllung schon mal fertig
und der teig das sollte schon so etwa
eine halbe stunde lang wohnen dürfen
ok schneebesen war nicht die beste wahl
dann fange ich so einmal schnell und
während die füllung jetzt hier an der
seite schon mal stehen kann
da kann ich schon mal auf die fleisch
führung zu bereiten und wie gesagt
bereite ich da einfach noch mal den teig
zu
nur damit ihr wisst wer wieviel menge
dann später eben auch der teig gedacht
ist
und die sahen und die brauche ich gleich
zum übergießen und die kommt nicht in
erfüllung
für die fleisch variante brauche ich 500
gramm hackfleisch da können wir in der
in flaschen oder rind und lamm sogar
gemischt schmeckt auch richtig gut eine
zwiebel 50 gramm wasser öl brauche ich
jetzt hier nicht weil er das hackfleisch
ungenügend wert hat und dann hier noch
die gewürze da hab ich jetzt zwei
teelöffel salz einem teelöffel pfeffer
einen halben teelöffel majoran und etwas
berg bohnenkraut ja im prinzip muss ich
jetzt hier nur die zwiebel ganz fein
schneiden
ihr könnt auch gerne zwei zwiebeln
nehmen ich glaube ich noch eine dazu
weil die relativ kleines es war schön
sich schmecken
und hier aber auch bei der vegetarischen
version darf die füllung ruhig etwas so
ganz leicht gesalzen schmecken denn da
teig hat ja gar kein salz drin
das heißt da jetzt einfach keine angst
haben und nicht so wenig würze
das gleicht sich dann später wegen
[Musik]
ich mag es überschneidende mister
geschälte kartoffeln gibt es ein glas
warum gibt es keine gestellten von
gespielt und für mich nicht weil ich
glaube dass bei köchen ich einfach die
zwiebel so schnell zu schneiden was der
tramp erst gar nicht da hingelangt und
dadurch das schon verarbeitet
ok und hier tritt im prinzip alles nur
verrührt also das hackfleisch kommt
jetzt hier vor ein
das wasser brauche ich damit das ganze
nicht so fest wird hier noch die ziele
und die kräuter des backbones hat muss
ich noch ein bisschen zerkleinern
das habe ich nämlich aus dem garten ist
trocken ich dann immer und ich glaube
ich mache das jetzt einfach mal so und
dann ist die füllung hier auch bereit
und da gibt es aber auch abwandlungen
also das ist es nicht die einzige
füllung dieser gibt ihr könnt auf jetzt
was mit lauch machen mit spinat
ihr könnt ihr gerne die kommentare
schreiben was so eure lieblings füllung
ist jetzt nehmt ihr euch am besten ein
baumwolltuch mit hier stecke zum
beispiel manche nehmen auch ein
bettlaken
ich habe hier ein tuch das benutze ich
wirklich nur in der küche man sieht auch
hier ganz deutlich hier habe ich schon
einige flecken hier wird gleich der teig
gezogen aber zuerst einmal muss ich hier
ausrollen und teilen jetzt schon mal in
drei portionen 1
jedoch lässt schon weil klebt nicht
wirklich jetzt einfach kurz dritteln
ihr könnt ihn auch vierteln dann werden
eure treue einfach etwas kleiner dieser
woche okay die zweite ich jetzt nicht
benutzter lege ich so lang wird
eigentlich schüssel zurück und steckte
ab ob ich aus und den ersten teigrolle
ich jetzt einfach mitnehmen aus so weit
wie es geben im ausfall starb
ihr könnt auch hier wenn ihr möchtet
direkt ein oxer wahrnehmen also so ein
holzstab wartet dann zeige ich euch da
hat mein papa einfach irgendwann so ein
besenstiel genommenen sauberen und denen
einfach zugeschnitten
damit geht es auch einfach aber ihr
braucht trotzdem auch wenn ihre
normalerweise sitzt später das tuch denn
mit dem tod geht das ganze noch ein
bisschen dünner
hier rollt man sie in der mitte auf und
kann dann praktisch durch so leichter
bewegungen nach außen streichen und dann
mit der zeit aber wie gesagt reicht da
auch in normaler aus rom starb wie bei
sonne aus wie bei so einem apfelstrudel
glaube ich hier das übrige melap legt
den teig hierüber hier wird er jetzt mit
öl bestrichen und es sorgt gleich dafür
dass er elastisch wird und sich schön
ziehen lässt ich bestreite erst mal die
hälfte schlags datum und so sind dann
alle flächen schönen gefettet und es
muss ich jetzt hier so 23 minuten ruhen
lassen
ich will jetzt auch schon mal den
nächsten tag aus allerdings könnte jetzt
hier nicht viel vorbereiten und nicht
vor arbeiten denn der teig dafür zu
weder zu lange ruhen noch zu kurz
ansonsten werde einfach riesig das
kriegt man auch so mit der zeit raus
selbst wenn es mal reist ist auch nicht
schlimm habe ich lass dir ne 23 minuten
ruhen montiert den nächsten aus den
hätte ich aber nicht sondern macht es
dann wirklich ganz frisch vorher
[Musik]
schweiz hier mit den fingern unter den
teig ganz ganz vorsichtig und zieht ihn
jetzt hier entlang und ihr seht schon
das tuch hält dann praktisch den teig
fest wenn jetzt kein tuch habt dann
zieht er sich nämlich wieder zusammen
und die struktur des tuwass hält ihn
einfach schön fest jetzt wirklich schön
vorsichtig gern auch so über den
handrücken
wenn man was löchrig wird ist es auch
nicht schlimm
[Musik]
jedes mal denke ich so gut da kam nicht
mehr da kann ich mir aber ihr seht schon
gerade hier der rand den wirklich auch
schön find ziehen damit er nicht hart
wird sondern eher so knusprig wird den
halt wie ich jetzt hier einmal und die
füllung die könnt ihr euch so vorstellen
ich habe drei plätze also kann ich das
hier einmal halbieren und dann drittel
also in sechs teile einteilen und hier
schön gleichmäßig verteilen
wichtig ist dass wir jetzt auf die länge
das ganze teilt damit die rolle
gleichmäßig dick wird
[Musik]
nehmt ihr einfach das tuch zu hilfe die
können es hier schön einschlagen und
zusammenrollen
[Musik]
und dann nehme ich hier schon ein
kleines system ein blech das hätte ich
jetzt so ein bisschen bei der
größenangabe bin ich jetzt bisschen
vorsichtig denn meine freundin hat es
mir natürlich so richtig gezeigt so wird
hierfür ein bisschen davon und die größe
guckt man halt wie es rein passt ich
gucke jetzt einfach dass sich die menge
bei euch für den also auf den block
richtig reinschreiben kann ich denke
jetzt nämlich aus einem bauchgefühl
heraus würde ich zwei kleine blätter
machen aber vielleicht passt auch in ein
ganz großes blech könnt ihr dann selbst
entscheiden und ich nehme zieht die
erste rolle
die wickel ich jetzt hier schon mal auf
und ihr könnt jetzt entweder mehrere
kleine machen oder eine große und die
erste rolle dann hier rein legen
und die zweite lege ich dann hier drüber
bzw außen rum
das kann jetzt kurz zur seite und dann
geht es wie gesagt mit dem nächsten tag
weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also als ein teil kommt jetzt auch hier
rein und die anderen 3d jetzt gleich
formel ins nächste blech so habe ich
jetzt zwei schöne voller löcher und das
ende
das kommt jetzt hier drunter das ist
nämlich nicht ganz so schön aus aber so
gefällt mir richtig gut
und so ist es auch schon bereit für den
backofen ich habe den bereits auf 200
grad ober unterhitze vorbereitet und
vorgeheizt und es werde jetzt so erstmal
nicht gestrichen sondern wird gebacken
und nach etwa 20 25 minuten also nach
der ersten backzeit die sich dann die
sahne drüber und die teile ich jetzt
auch gleich auf beide bleche das heißt
100 gramm pro blech und dann wird es
noch mal fertig gebacken und wie gesagt
könnt ihr das so erstmal vorbereiten und
backen und nach dem abkühlen einspielen
und wenn es dann frisch nochmal auf
backen wollte einfach erwerben sahne
darübergeben und servieren das ist so
der verbreitung strikt ab mit ihren den
backofen bei 200 grad
dort die fleischige variante macht ihr
im prinzip fast genauso da verteilt ihr
dann die fleisch füllung hier und die
form ich jetzt aber ein bisschen anders
dann haben sie noch eine variation das
werden jetzt kleine schnecken und hier
auch darauf achten dass hier außen genug
füllung ist und wirklich die füllung
gleichmäßig verteilt wird
[Musik]
jetzt verschwindet
jetzt könnt ihr euch hier die rolle
nehmen und einfach so kleine schnecken
machen hier abzupfen und geht dann gerne
auch ein
[Musik]
es darf noch bevor es durch diesen denn
jetzt noch ein bisschen zu hell
ich warte jetzt noch das ist ein
bisschen farbe hat und dann kommt erst
die sahne drüber ich habe übrigens
gerade umgebaut denn für diese variante
nämlich jetzt einfach das größte blech
ich denke da passen gleich alle rein ist
es nächste schon fertig kann ich schon
mal weitermachen und hier mache ich
jetzt gleich alle rein
[Musik]
super aus und jetzt wie gesagt 100 gramm
sahne problems hin zungenbrecher ist
jetzt schon 1 80 und cremig und kann
jetzt so fertig gebacken werden
hmm
topthema so sieht perfekt aus das hole
ich raus und dann wird gleich mit
schmand verliert und die fleisch
variante die braucht ihr gar nicht mit
sahne zu übergießen denn die hat schon
genug eingeschätzt durch das fleisch und
die wird später auch mit schmand
serviert entspanntere joghurt
[Musik]
das kita und bürger sind fertig heute
auf daniel probieren ja heute hab ich
gebacken einmal direkt dass es mit
fleisch und einmal peter vegetarisch ich
muss sagen rein optisch gefällt mir das
besser als das bin ich heute aber es hat
mal ausprobieren denn man kann es auch
so zubereiten aber ich bin es nächstes
mal alles als schnecke auf rollen ja
probieren können wir servieren dazu
stand aber ihr könnt auch jo packen
jetzt gibt es sowas schon mal gegessen
ich muss ehrlich sein ja ok
bei meinem besten freund aber jeder
komme ich nicht dagegen an gegen mütter
kommen natürliche hausmannskost aber ich
glaube ich muss so
so in 15 jahren bin ich ebenso die musik
die ich komme ja in 15 jahren
wir haben sie als alter mensch war
gesagt kann schmid mahnt das ist so
großem erstaunen
das stimmt ich hab das rezept von fikret
ich möchte leben
ich möchte jetzt sagen würde es werde
nicht mit minimum genauso ich probiert
dass ich so gern vor der kamera
hiermit bestätigt mit zehn punkte 1 bis
ich habe ihr schwarm ihr seid richtig
sparsam mit geld sie kaum haben die
punkte aus dem ausland von zehn und den
sco sehen wir das maximum
also schmeckt die wird wahrscheinlich
nicht nachmachen aber noch mal wissen
ich glaube ich könnte so einfach nicht
nur noch machen das wäre das problem
wollen schon aber nur die frage wer hält
und man sich sehr sehr meditativ
erfahrung ja also mir gesagt könnt ihr
das rezept super vorbereiten
wenn ihr das jetzt tatsächlich zum
ramadan machen möchtet würde ich dazu
empfehlen dass ihr das vielleicht so als
hauptspeise habt und dann vorher
vielleicht eine suppe dazu habt oder im
salat noch dazu einfach was leichtes
warmes für den magen und dann ebenso
eine teigige fleischige hauptspeise ja
kaum davon kann man schon nicht so viel
essen menschen so salat dazu oder eine
suppe probiert das rezept gerne mal auch
auf cds - glock de findet ihr es und
natürlich auch hinter app die
sprühflasche ja also erstmal vor wie
zwei abschriften also bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]